breaking news just come in to us in the
last few moments regarding Kenneth Moyer
former gangster he was a convicted of
murder he has been released from prison
according to the ministry of justice
he had served nearly 20 years for
killing Stephen Cameron he was 21 at the
time on an m25 slit Road near swanly in
Kent which was back in 1996 the murder
took place in front of Mr Cameron's 17
year old fiance mr. Moy was on license
from a previous prison term at the time
of the attack a very short statement for
the Ministry of Justice and they say we
understand this will be a distressing
position for the family of Stephen
Cameron and our thoughts remain with
them like all life sentences prisoners
released by the independent parole board
kenneth nor will be on licence for the
remainder of his life subject to strict
conditions in the faces a return to
prison should he fail to comply so the
breaking news and this afternoon at
Kenneth's know a former gangster
convicted of murder has been released
from prison according to the Ministry of
Justice